the jurogan experience i don't know how
it was in china
wha in wuhan were all the businesses
doing the same thing were they building
little heaters and like and
potted plants so you could have outdoor
dining or was this a capitalistic thing
i think the government shut them the
[ __ ] down i mean they were bolting
people inside their houses right with
like the
evidence tape across the doors it's not
good i mean the way they handled it is
scary i don't think we should handle it
the way they handled it but
even that didn't necessarily work i mean
didn't they have a
another surge like one of the things
they were pointing to like japan they
were pointing to japan
as being a virus success story right
they just
social distancing they were their mass
went back to work and everybody's fine
not true they have a huge surge there
right now the problem is this virus is
weird
yeah and i don't think there's a real
way that you can contain it los angeles
contained it
in in terms of like the strictness of
their lockdowns but more than anybody
right there they're they were stricter
than anybody they have the most cases
now
they're [ __ ] i know you were saying
that and it seems like it affects
everybody differently
yeah you ask a doctor a question you
know
they don't know the answer and are isn't
our human brain
trying to find patterns so we can go
okay that's what this sickness is but
this thing seems to be all over the
place
yeah it doesn't have good patterns and
it affects people very differently in
terms of like what it does to them some
people it's like a sinus infection some
people it really
knocks them for a loop yeah some people
don't recover and they die
and it doesn't make it does there's no
pattern that makes sense
yeah like the flu we understand the flu
is dangerous
kills people really does but we also
understand what to do
get a flu shot you know boost your
immune system
here's here's some medication you can
take with this
well like this is so new and so scary
that no one knows what to do
i i tried to find comfort in reading
about this the
pandemic of 1918 because that the
spanish flu because that was supposedly
two years and i was like
okay well how did we get through that
did the economy recover you know i was
trying to like use history as a way to
predict the future but when you read
about it at least the wikipedia page of
the pandemic of 1918.
we never really fixed it or it it like
possibly is still around that that virus
and it was i thought
maybe a vaccine fixed it no it didn't i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened to the
spanish flu
was it hurt immunity i don't know i
don't
probably yeah but you know you'll find
it it's estimated
that that's killed like 50 million
people yeah uh
so i hope 100 years later we're better
at this stuff
um never really ended after affecting
millions
worldwide the 1918 flu stream shifted
and then stuck around
oh great
well there's a new version that's
december 11. it's a software update
there's a new version
of kovid that's in that's hit london now
70
more transmittable yeah [ __ ] fun
times what we know what we don't about
the uk coronavirus variant
and they think there might have been a
similar variant or the same variant in
brazil
a few months ago crazy not good
so do we live in fear do we risk
yeah yeah we just hit our pants and hide
yeah or you
you [ __ ] take care of your immune
system and you allow people to open up
businesses
here's the thing these these people that
are making these decisions for us like
the mayor of la and the governor of
california
right which is the worst examples they
they're not
experts in the right thing to do or the
wrong thing to do because
what they've done has worked terribly
it's been the worst response and
i don't think you can do something and
not
have a consideration for the
consequences the negative consequences
of what you're doing
like telling people they can't work and
shut down their businesses
when the economy collapses because all
these things are shut down
and yet you still don't have a
significant decrease
in the cases like what you're showing is
you have this one idea you're sticking
with it and you're not
there's no indication that you have any
respect for the negative consequences
not only that you don't have a plan like
how are you going to bring everybody
back up how are you going to how you
bring back these restaurants what are
you gonna do about these comedy clubs
that are dead
what are you gonna do about these bars
that are going under what are you gonna
do with these mom and pop shops that are
never gonna be around anymore
i don't know how it is in your life but
in my life
numerous friends of mine in what
appeared to be
healthy strong relationships
they're [ __ ] toast yeah like pandemic
has divorced a lot of people
yeah domestic violence is up suicides
suicides are up so there is a different
consequence to all this now
i also find it entertaining that we
elect these officials and then now they
have to be in charge of a
health crisis i would much rather we
elect them off of popularity or whatever
it is
and then when a health crisis strikes we
have a health minister
who kind of comes in and just like drops
the heat on us the problem with these
health ministers
is in a situation like this they don't
even
take into account the economic
consequences
and right that the economic consequences
are also going to bring with them
suicide drug addiction domestic violence
child abuse
all those things are going to happen and
they don't take into account that they
take into account
the health consequences and here's the
other thing these
governors and these mayors that shut
everything down still get paid
right that's a that's a real problem
they are not incentivized to keep
businesses open
if they were if their pay was in direct
like if they were like the ceo of a
company right where
the more money the company makes the
more money they make they
would be incentivized to make sure these
businesses stay open and these people
can
keep paying taxes these [ __ ] keep
getting paid
no matter what happens but they have a
term limit they do
but yeah but so what look by the time
newsom gets out
he will have destroyed that state and
also destroyed people's faith in
government because people are so
frustrated with him and then you see him
at that french laundry place
sitting around right next to people
indoors
always outdoor dining [ __ ] there's a
chandelier above your [ __ ] head not
stars there's not stars above your head
there's walls
yeah there's yeah i know that's i don't
want to hear your [ __ ]
yeah you are a hypocrite and this is
nonsense you
should not be getting paid yeah if you
if you let your economy
collapse due to these decisions that are
not based on science
like particularly outdoor dining it's
not based on science there's no data
they can't show we have overwhelming
data that you know
50 of the transmissions are due to
people eating outside right that's not
the case
so we're fortunate in la that you have
very good weather
so keep the [ __ ] restaurants open
that can open outside
help them accommodate them give them
some sort of a bridge
to let them get through this so that on
the other side after the vaccines that
have to hurt immunity or whatever
happens
these people will still have businesses
catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience